when I was 26 years old I began losing a
lot of hair I was terrifying but I
wouldn't change a thing about how
everything is unfolded my name is
Anthony Carrigan I'm an actor and I have
alopecia alopecia areata is a it's an
autoimmune disorder in which your body
thinks that something's wrong with it
and so it attacks the hair follicles and
and because of that you lose patches of
hair I was very shy as a kid when I
first started acting I began to kind of
discover this voice within myself so
when I lost a lot of my hair I had no
idea what to do
I didn't know if I could still be an
actor I didn't know if I could remain in
this business that was so so image
focused but then I found something
within me that was worth fighting for I
found a whole new perspective on the way
that I looked I found a whole new
perspective on what kind of characters I
could play and I began to cultivate that
I have been typecast as as the villain I
think it isn't just me bald guys
throughout history have played the
villain some of the TV shows that I've
been in I was on an episode of the
blacklist flash on CW the Gotham on Fox
for the longest time I tried to kind of
create a certain self that didn't have
alopecia because a lot of the time we
feel like we need to put on a face and
that's just not real it's all about
being human and it being okay to not be
perfect